welcome to how to think like Shakespeare
on examination of Shakespeare across
disciplines I'm Kenji Yoshino joined
here by Jim Shapiro and Carol Gilligan
and right now we are talking about
Shakespeare abused are there
appropriations of Shakespeare that you
just feel like are out of bounds that
should not be that if you could push a
button and make them go away you would
I'm wondering if the language is such
that that you know no matter how bad the
acting no matter how dreadful the
interpretation that I just saw a
production of check off that was I
thought so bad so I just closed my eyes
and listen to the language and it was so
gorgeous but I think you could do that
with chase I think you can you you know
it's really fascinating question you
know the lines like neither a barn or
lender be its most often quoted
Shakespeare lineament right or let's
Polonius you know but it's still a good
axiom to live by right so who cares if
they get it wrong it seems sort of
pedantic to say you know what you know
you do realize that this is one of the
greatest asses in Shakespeare that
you're quoting well it's like to dine
own self be true used to have to say
that that was one of the graces that
can't some camp I went to a strip you
know who says no is a moment I just saw
a really brilliant Hamlet in London at
the national theatre and Polonius said
that line in a way that I'd never heard
it before he's going on and on with all
these you know I for a stick nonsense
and full of himself and he says to their
own self be true and he catches himself
and in that moment you realize he
recognizes how untrue he has been Hamlet
senior oh just awful oh these opens up
in him and he just freezes and then he
regains some composure but he's not the
same after that and I thought what a
brilliant brilliant reading of that line
so just keep going to these productions
to to pray for a moment like that then
it just opens up the play and the
characters and ways that are really
waiting to be
over that's wonderful thank you both for
your insights to see more of the
Shakespeare series please visit